hello everybody my name is Mark Blart
welcome back to subnautica as you can
see we're back on the shipping was that
me releasing toxic fart gas into the
ocean should I be worried about that or
was that the ship that's probably about
to explode
again I really wonder what would happen
if you were here when it exploded I mean
besides death of course so anyway what
we're doing now is we're gonna explore
the ship more thoroughly and try to find
some possibly rare resources because I
imagine there has to be some good stuff
coming around here and I do have first
aid kits which should aid me in this and
and also yes my hair is blue again I
didn't change it I was gonna go with
either blue purple or red but they
didn't have time to sit in the chair for
14 hours to get it bleached all over
again because when that when you get
that done it takes forever okay so I saw
this this was no signal I might have
gotten something from there I don't
think I did just get some water at the
moment okay so I'm gonna try to explore
the ship and not fall like a stupid
ninny into a pit of him whatever the
hell those crabs were they look like
head crabs from halflife way back when
is anyone else creeped out by this I
mean there's a little bit of sinister
eNOS going on here I mean I don't know
if it's just the noises or whatnot but
there's some bad stuff happening you I
mean since uh the evidence that we found
in the last episode kind of pointed
towards the idea that this was sabotage
and not necessarily just you know an
accident oh god oh I see the things in
the background okay so I got to make
sure that I don't throw myself headfirst
into those things
is that's where I went wrong okay so
there's gotta be something around here
unless there isn't I didn't get a chance
to get your advice if there was or was
not some thing around here don't know
don't don't don't don't
I got a knife I ain't afraid to use it
okay I don't know how the hell I'm gonna
do that I guess this is some skill
walking here god I wish it was not the
middle of night oh God here we go okay
there's got to be something over here
there's just ah to be because I am smart
and filled with brain juice excuse me
sir don't mind me little buddy hey don't
be jumping like that
I got a sly see way see a trace human
remains detected nearby organics
digestive system further exploration not
advised Oh
Hongki I am a brave man I'm gonna dive
headfirst into those gullets and I'm
gonna be digested just along with all my
friends because I'm obsessed and alone
and slightly crazy from the isolation I
mean is there nothing else that I can go
to hey there we go spike great disinfect
water well I guess that's now get out of
here hey ha oh god that kind of hurt not
that bad though not that bad not that
bad it's not that bad I'm like Rocky
it's not that bad okay
other than supply crates I don't know
what else is gonna be around here dumb
but I'm hoping for like some rare
crafting crap but if it's just
disinfected and you know sorry I've been
fighting a throw thing for a while now
what is that signal oh hey okay did we
find something good is that good did I
do good that sounded like it might have
been good I don't know what the signal
is signaling for see I've already gotten
that one
oh this could be good and this kind of
ramps off into the water so this might
be an entry point to the water if I get
lost I think that's one there's got to
be a whole bunch of new stuff battery I
guess that's kind of useful
but this doesn't why is it rumbling good
possible what does that mean
possible cave opening cool how do I get
I need to go back to my seem off there's
a possible cave opening over there I
don't know what that means I've never
seen that before in my life is that
because I got the signal is this gonna
be a signal for a clue to get something
maybe there's other survivors hopefully
a woman or a man I'll take anything at
this point I'm rather desperate okay
anyway so God that is so terrifying just
the drop off suit drop off into the
abyss over there I mean I see little
glowing lights but I'm gonna need my
seamoth if I'm gonna be able to go to
get that I mean I'm just waiting for the
point where there's gonna be an even
bigger monster that wants to come say hi
to me it's not gonna be too friendly
when that happens oh I forgot to add
this thing air with me it's been a while
oh god it's so creepy oh god it's so
creepy
okay so I did find something cool though
I don't know if it's significant in your
mind or my mind but this is significant
to me because if it's possible cave
opening I mean it's gonna suck if I get
there and it's not a cave opening oh
those the other possibility though oh
yes I shouldn't have been too excited
about it but if hey buddy how I get my
guitar you're good good good good good
good good yes please thank you hi Karen
there seems to be a sand shark that
wants my butt oh hey oh god is that
thresher hey leave that alone
that's my eventual Salvage oh god dunk
okay man I hope fuelling up the seamoth
of where whoa what ammo wow I have no
idea how I did that I got so confused
there sorry
everybody I'm still new to this and it's
pitch black ha ha ha excuse me ok so
where the hell would that be in relation
to everything and maybe I could skirt
along the sea floor and kind of there
are supply boxes so excuse me
don't mind me Oh Oh God where am I
Oh why does it pop me on like that okay
do another signal ooh cool the signals
lead to possible cave openings I have no
idea what that means but I'm so excited
okay so there's a pasta yeah now I got
two possible cave openings well that's
cool I think I still have no idea what
that means but hey it's progress
hooray progress and I guess I can just
skirt along the floor and open these
things up
god damnit stuff dear man another Sagada
nother one there's a signals all over
the place maybe it's not that rare I
thought me going into the ship was
actually gonna be good and I had some
purpose to it I guess I guess in the end
my life just isn't all that special then
fine story of my life
okay now that possible cave opening that
possible cave opening and I don't see
another so I guess those two are in ok
so I guess what I get to the possible
cave opening I'm gonna kind of find most
likely I'm gonna find like some obstacle
in the way that's I need to get around
God is so beautiful what's so terrifying
please could it be day I miss having fun
and being happy and feeling joy in my
heart well you know when the day was
around
huh by that huh
what are you Oh get off of my thing I
didn't know you were there I was gonna
scan a fragment hopefully it could have
been a seamoth like oh oh I remember you
where are you oh god no what are they
should I even go close to him
oh they're horrifying oh they look like
Reapers for mass effect and they seem to
have glowy testicles hello sir
uh uh don't shake your booty at me I'm
not interested in no mating dance with
you
oh I'm sorry I upset you but frankly I'm
a taken man
well not in real life but in this game
I'm gonna assume I am cuz I got a
computer wife and I love her dearly and
I got four beautiful baby boys Geoffrey
Billy samurais and Marshall and I
remember them all because that's the
kind of dad I am stop pooping like the
whole the whole topography of this area
over here is very different from where
I've started at I mean it's much more
barren and isolated but in a way it kind
of opens it a lot more and gives the
grand sense of the into hello grand
sense of the entire ocean that I'm
traversing it's all good all good and
again I apologize for the sniffling I'm
fighting back a little cold that's kind
of taking a little bit of my voice but
none too bad so there's that also improv
class is finally over at least for me
anyway looks like Ryan's gonna be doing
it for just a little bit longer and then
after that we got a ton of more stuff
not the creepvine why would I want to
scan the creepvine whoo stasis rifle
that sounds fun maybe that's gonna help
me in defending myself in this ocean of
death and terror yeah that anyway we're
pretty much done my show was fantastic
by the way I had a great time doing the
show because I've never like performed
live on stage and even though it wasn't
like a play or anything it was just an
improv show but I mean it was super fun
I've never had an experience like that
before I mean I've had panels in front
of you guys where the hell
I've had panels in front of you guys
before but not to the extent where it's
like it's a live show and I was this
here before I think I would have noticed
it right by my house oh oh no oh no no
no no no no oh no no no oh lordy no oh
god no oh god no okay here we go oh boy
well I'm not I'm not doing the spinning
by the way I am sure okay cool what is
that oh what is that oh what is that oh
what is this what what is this Oh God
what the hell I walked across oh no I
don't want to be here oh this is bad
Oh God what are you ha ha ha god I feel
more scared than I have in all the
horror games I played in the past few
years I just don't want to go forward oh
it's so scary ok calm down a little bit
never mind ok sorry I guess I can't go
down there god I need to upgrade my
seamoth but Wow
can I even exit I bet I can't even get
out of this because it'll really hurt me
won't it Oh God
oh that's so scary oh oh ok we're gonna
come back to this after I can upgrade my
seamoth a little more maybe even upgrade
my suit because let me just step out
right here ok what happens if I go down
so far so good so far so good
ooh that red doesn't look good okay what
I'm going to do is I'm gonna get my
seamoth right up against the border
because there's probably some materials
down here that are a little more rare so
let me see what this is just get an idea
of what copper alright not too rare
thanks Karen love you baby okay so if I
get right up on the border of 225 and
then step out okay I mean I seem okay so
far it's not giving me any warnings all
sudden I just crushed like a paper cup
whoa let him that sounds cool what the
hell are you no idea can I slice you off
a piece break you off a piece No
okay god damn it's so pretty but I'm so
scared
I gotcha Karen thanks for looking at
water though oh those are just people
fish okay so that's nothing new
so God that is so disorienting so I'm
gonna try to find more outcroppings
first okay there's one over there and I
whole bunch okay so this should be good
from all this tons okay I didn't even
see that I thought it was super rare
okay so perfect gold
I got gold before still cool though I
mean it's cool that I got gold but I
didn't know what to do with the gold
besides like it was like a power
transmitter that I could get whoa oh
that was gold it was red thirty seconds
oh god Oh fresh hell oh god get me there
Jesus okay so my oxygen reclaims slowly
in here so I got to be a bit more
cautious but man look at this place I
mean seriously this is nuts in here this
is bonkers oh man it just goes to show
that I have not explored even remotely
all that this game has to offer and
just just in the same way it's like you
know the our oceans have not been
explored hardly at all and there's a lot
of stuff that we do not know about our
own oceans all right I also think my my
oxygen is definitely going down quicker
than you so I'm just gonna get these and
get back and one more I can make it I
can make it heal there all right so
that's enough for now and then i'ma head
back and I must see what I can do with
these new materials because I do not
think oh well that's some sassy music
won't tell me why all right
oh there's one more right there okay I
mean it's cool music not really the
majestic ocean type of music but you
know it's pretty good sorry pardon me I
wish I was perfectly healthy at all
times but it always seems I'm coming
down with something
okay so just had to NAB those real quick
all right now we're gonna head back to
base and see what we can do with these
materials oh you weren't there before
all right I'll scan you oh this is just
seamoth fragment this is gonna be okay
so actually it's time to end the episode
unfortunately but I'm gonna keep playing
more of this game so let me know what I
should do with these new materials let
me know how best to go through these
caves and thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video the figure or something
that popped up in front 20 I mean who
wouldn't be if any of you my lovely
Flanders